as the 2019 season approaches we are
counting down the top 30 storylines for
the NFL's 100th season and number 8 has
father time begun to catch up with
number 9 from the New Orleans Saints
Drew Brees there were signs of it last
year and some would say that we first
saw it in that Thursday night lost to
the Dallas Cowboys one week after the
Thanksgiving night win by the Saints
over the Falcons some would say that
maybe it came a little bit earlier
however the indications are there that
Drew Brees who is now 40 years old may
not be the guy that he once was and if
he wants to use that as motivation
feel free all we're doing is objectively
analyzing what we see and what we've
seen from Tom Brady once he turned 40 is
two seasons of stellar quarterback play
two seasons of Super Bowl births one win
and one loss and the Super Bowl loss
wasn't because of anything that Tom
Brady did that day that's for damn sure
so we've come to expect that once guys
hit 40 they'll be able to continue to
play like they always have with Brees
it's going to be a real question this
year whether or not he really is the
same guy and and here's how it goes with
a franchise quarterback there's a
healthy creative tension between the
quarterback and the play caller in this
case Saints coach Sean Payton Payton
will come up with a number of plays that
are designed to give Drew Brees
easy stats easy yards easy touchdowns
and then there will be a certain number
of instances where Drew Brees through
his sheer passing ability will give the
team easy touchdowns and easy yards and
it's a symbiotic relationship between
play caller and quarterback and as long
as both sides hold up their end of the
bargain it works well with the Saints
could it be that the pendulum is
swinging more toward the play caller
than the quarterback and and there's one
play that that I'll focus on and I've
mentioned this before
nikhyl Roby Coleman Tommy Lee Lewis the
play that we spend so much time talking
about because of the failure to spot
pass interference in real time which d
legitimate I think the Rams birth in the
Superbowl and I wonder how much of a
distraction it was for the Rams
they got ready for the Super Bowl that
they felt like maybe they didn't belong
there because they got away with one you
know when you you kind of feel guilty
when you think you got away with one and
I don't want to go down that rabbit hole
but but you could make the argument you
could make the argument that it affected
the Rams moving forward the point is if
there is a point there is one bear with
me that Drew Brees could have gotten
that ball to Tommy Lee Lewis faster the
Drew Brees could have seen him faster
and delivered the ball more quickly
because what happened was Nickell Robbie
Coleman was on the other side of the
field and he saw that Tommy Lee Lewis
was uncovered Roby Coleman was out of
position he sprinted across the field
and he got there in time to disrupt the
catch just before the ball arrived well
you could argue that Drew Brees of two
or three years ago would have put the
ball into Tommy Lewis's grasp before
Roby Coleman got there and maybe Louis
would have been in the in the end zone
with the touchdown before Coleman got
over to the other side of the field so
the ability to recognize adapt deliver
the football quickly is father time a
factor in that as it relates to that key
play from the NFC Championship game and
those are the kinds of things that we
need to watch as the 2019 season unfolds
and look they use Taysom Hill to throw
the deep passes remember that Sunday
night game against the Vikings there's
Taysom Hill throwing the ball 50 yards
down the field
Kendra Brees simply not throw the ball
that far down the field anymore will we
see more Taysom Hill this year see I
father times gonna win against all these
guys whether it's Brady whether it's
Brees whether it's anybody else who is
getting close to 40 the question is once
it begins to happen how will the player
adapt well the player be in denial and
try to do things he can't do or will the
player accept it and color within the
lines as those lines begin to constrict
so an important issue to watch for the
Saints this year they're already have
enough to deal with two straight post
seasons of devastating losses different
circumstances but still devastating the
Minneapolis miracle in 2017 and then
that horrible blown call in 2018 but
through it all the real question is have
we seen the best of Drew Brees
I think we have the question is is
what's left of Drew Brees
good enough to carry the Saints back to
the postseason and maybe back to the
Super Bowl that's something that we're
going to be watching throughout the 2019
season
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports